we had this story from the
post-millennial daily wires Jeremy
boring launches new Chocolate Company in
response to Hershey's woke trans stunt
they did this so fast I am impressed I
will play for you the video right
because they're just re-wrapping
chocolate that exists well but that's
all chocolate is yeah it like like all
these everyone's got a coffee company
yeah like I did not buy a coffee roaster
and then you know I think I think the
quarter of Jeremy the Quarry literally
did literally yeah what we did was we
found a provider we we talked to them
about the blend that we wanted and the
kind of coffee that we like and they're
creating for us a specific thing and
then we put our label on it because it's
our version of a coffee so they'll make
a bunch of different kinds of coffee
what we're doing is combining the ones
we like and then selling it under our
name
but here's here's a commercial for you
guys International women's day is a I
got it hold on there we go upon us again
and I love an international woman but
our friends over at Hershey's they don't
even know what a woman is they've hired
a biological male to be the spokesperson
for their women's day campaign and
they're calling that campaign and I
swear I'm not making this up her she
Hershey it's humiliating and it's the
reason I'm watching
Jeremy's chocolate we have two kinds
she her
and he him
one of them's got nuts if you need me to
tell you which one it is
laughing giving your money to whoa
corporations that hate you and you're
looking for a delicious chocolate bar
from a company that actually wants your
business head over to ihatehersheys.com
and Order Jeremy's chocolate today I I
I'm sorry man the daily wire does
awesome stuff that this is brilliant uh
I I said when the whole uh Hershey
women's day trans thing happened I was
like you shouldn't boycott Hershey
because they hired a trans person okay
you should not do that you should
boycott Hershey because it's disgusting
garbage sugar that kills you and you
should eat an avocado or something I
thought you were gonna make a ginger
joke about the trans person yeah if it
doesn't say food I don't know they're
probably using slave labor to acquire
the cacao if it doesn't say fair trade
on the past would you what if what if
the daily wire chocolate is like the
most brutal dictator oh Jeremy get fair
trade bro I'll buy it if it's fair trade
I want it more now if not I gotta say
Brett Cooper held it down in that video
she's awesome I think as an actor she's
gonna be like a superstar in the world
and it's just now building up the
comment section but she came she was a
child actor in Hollywood and they hired
her so when you go to I hate Hershey's
it actually brings you to
jeremy'srazers.com
and uh and then you can buy Jeremy's
chocolate binary
brilliant nuts nuts and nutless and uh
I'll tell you what they did
they probably as soon as this happened
they had someone design she or him
they probably bought a chocolate bar
from Walgreens or whatever supermarkets
they have in in Nashville and then just
printed out the paper wrapped it around
the thing for a prop then they went they
called the bespoke chocolate labeler and
they said we want to sell the chocolate
and they said we can have it packaged
for you because when you go to Hershey
Park
you can actually get your own bar made
like there's this thing where you walk
into this room and then you pick what
you want like I want white chocolate
with toffee bits and then I want it
covered in dark chocolate Hershey
Pennsylvania
yeah yeah I went to that factory once
yeah we we went there a little while ago
I won't go there now but uh they make a
box and everything and the funny thing
is when I went there they do this thing
where they take the first three letters
of your last name
and then put it on your bar so when I
got my chocolate with nuts and it was
lumpy and brown it had the first three
letters of my last name on the box and
so I went to the the woman who was
running I said ma'am can I can I get a
different label for this box and she was
a young man first and he goes no you
can't and I was like my God I am not
going to spend was like 50 bucks on a
poo bar
You Got It You Gotta Give me a better
box for this if you told me they would
do that I would not have put my last
name on The Box
and so then the lady came over looked at
it and started laughing and I was like I
was kind of perturbed that they told me
no you're the poo bar
and so when the lady came back and
started laughing at first I was a little
irk but I started laughing too and I was
like it's amazing isn't it and then she
took it and she gave me a new box but
they they like there's a machine that
does it all so I didn't get the properly
sealed box like everybody else got
because mine said poo on it they had to
give me a stock box and then just drop
it in there and then tape it shut and
I'm like you know this is you can't win
but that that anyway some people got a
rough anyway story aside uh you you
should like
I I'll probably end up I think I'm gonna
buy a crapload of this stuff I think I'm
gonna buy like 500 bars and I'm gonna
have them downstairs for guests and for
employees and it's going to be funny
because you're gonna walk in and and and
you know what's it actually says nuts
and nutless on them
I I love it I love Jeremy I love daily
wire but I don't want to have sugar
that's my only downside if it was a
product like a meatless meat yeah
whatever look the worst that's not what
I mean the worst thing about when I try
to get that Hershey bar is that I I put
everything in it so like when I was what
it is it's like it's like a bowl it's a
chocolate bar with with a with an edge
around it to hold the stuff in and I was
like I want white chocolate chips I want
chocolate chips I want toffee bits so it
created this big Mound and then it
blankets it it was it called in robes it
in chocolate and robes and so what comes
out everyone else has like this thin
normal looking bar and mine's lumpy and
weird looking and then they wrote poo on
it and I was just like I was like come
on Photo up I probably should have just
taken it like that's right that's right
what a big lumpy chocolate I was like I
would have put a fake name if you told
me you're gonna do that was it good when
you ate it yeah of course it was it was
like too many ingredients because
Perkins back to the day of when I had no
money at Subway and I'd be like extra
everything and then that would be my
meal dude I'd go to Wendy's and I would
be like I would like the uh the dollar
menu Junior you know cheeseburger deluxe
or whatever and I want quadruple extra
tomato quadruple extra lettuce and
quadruple extra cheese like whatever's
free and then some places the cheese
like cheese is extra but sometimes they
would tell me they didn't care and I'd
be like how many tomatoes can I get they
were like I don't know tomatoes are free
and I was like kind of get seven they'd
be like I guess and I'm like I need food
and I'm poor yes
this is your belly so there's a lot of
people who aren't like the biggest fans
of the daily wire that aren't the most
bullish on The Daily wire and I think
you know the chocolate bar is a little
bit gimmicky the he him the the nutless
though even though this great line it's
a little bit gimmicky but I think you
really do need to give the daily wire so
much credit because they do so many
different things across the board
between Matt Walsh's lobbying for
different
um bands against you know these
conversions these trans conversion
surgeries in Tennessee or signing Jordan
Peterson or Jeremy's razors or I know
they're also doing children's books and
Chrissy maybe you could tell me a little
bit of some of their other projects
going on but they're just really willing
to work on these other projects and I
think a lot of people in the right wing
movement or conservative movement aren't
willing to put as many risks out
um like the daily wire seems to be doing
so I'm really bullish on them and I
think they're doing a great job and they
should continue doing stuff like this in
the space
yeah she's at a different company were
you previously at Daily one yeah okay so
previously yet I'm I'm ordering two
thousand dollars worth of Jeremy's
chocolate right now do it I'm not I'm
not even what's the website I hate
hersheys.com yeah
yeah they're getting some orders tonight
yeah I'm ordering 480 bars how many how
much how many years it's half of H just
240 of each I wonder if they made a
trans flavor like a half not half not I
think that's the whole or just a whole
nut if it's which yeah whole nut would
be a good well because no matter you
can't make it half and half either way
right there's no way to get to half an
order confirmed give me the nuts in the
trans man chocolate bar there's just
random things but they could they could
do they could do a bunch of stuff that
would be like funny to make fun of yeah
why don't they do like trans women and
just send you a bag of nuts that's well
but no but they could do like like I
don't know they could they're doing nuts
and nut lists like okay what else do you
got you can make uh like cookies and
cream and then oh yeah or you know you
could do one where it's um white
chocolate with uh I'm sorry I'm sorry no
it's got to be like banana cream with
white chocolate inside they can make
like an Americanized Asian joke or
something you know what I would really
love is a white and dark chocolate swirl
bar if you can pull that off they could
they could make like the an American
flag bar and they could be like you know
we don't need none of this there you go
we're Americans I mean actually that's a
really cool thing today like strawberry
in it or something well imagine this
imagine you like open the wrapper and
it's an American flag but it's a candy
bar and you got like strawberry white
chocolate and I guess blueberries watch
the food coloring don't use that
pharmaceutical tar coal tar you know
yellow five Lake and crap like that or
what is it petroleum-based I have no
idea no food coloring yeah the yellow
flies or something but no I I I I no
joke I just ordered uh 20 I think I
ordered 20 packs nice so that's what is
that 420 24 packs 480 it was two
thousand dollars but uh we went to
business here and um I'm pretty sure
that when we have guests here when they
go down and they it's not about eating
them it's about seeing it okay and
people are going to be like that's
awesome so it's an important business
purchase dude
it's important to support daily because
you like their projects and if you think
what they're doing is cool then sporting
them is great who do you think fast they
did it in like six hours who do you
think came up with nutless let's take a
toll I think it was Jared okay hold on I
don't know the daily wire guys we're
sitting around and like I'm imagining
Jeremy smoking a cigar and he's like we
should make a chocolate bar to like make
fun of Hershey's and someone's like oh
dude we should call it nutless and like
that's a great idea and they're like oh
yeah Michael Knowles comes in and
they're high-fiving each other like do
it
I think Knowles came up with it he
doesn't get enough credit he's smart
smart guy Candace suggested Candace
Owens suggested I start a hair care line
and I was like damn when Candice Owens
tells you should start a company you
should probably start the company it's
kind of like Rogan telling you you
should do this start doing it why was
she complimenting your hair yeah she was
like you got great whatever she didn't
give me the accomplish she was just like
you should do that and I'm like yeah man
they they are set up now daily wire
where they have that whole system ready
to go if they want to start a business
they got the lawyers they got the
business contacts they're like make it
happen and then they have a chocolate
company make it happen thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time